You know,
in,
in the Hobbit,
for example,
when,
what's his name,
Frodo,
right,
isn't,
it's not Bilbo,
Bilbo in Harvard,
you know,
he's kind of this little underdeveloped
overprotected shire dweller and he's
called on a great adventure to go and
find the dragon,
and he asked to become a thief in order
to manage it.
Well,
that's pretty weird,
you know,
it's like,
well,
it's because as a good citizen,
he's just not enough to conquer a
dragon.
He asked to also become a bad citizen in
some sense.
He has to incorporate the part of
themselves that's monstrous,
let's say,
and develop that and hone it.
And,
and that's to say that,
well,
if you're harmless,
you're not virtuous,
you're just harmless.
You're like a rabbit.
Rabbit isn't virtuous.
It's just,
just can't do anything except get eaten.
It's not virtuous.
If you're a monster and you don't act
monstrously,
then you're virtuous,
but you also have to be a monster while
you see this all the time.
Harry Potter's like that too.
It's like he's,
he's flawed,
he's hurt.
He's got evil in him.
He can talk to snakes,
man,
he breaks rules all the time,
all the time.
He's not an obedient at all,
but you know,
he has a good reason for breaking the
rules and if he couldn't break the
rules,
him and his little clique of rule
breaking troublemakers.
If they didn't break the rules,
they wouldn't attain the highest goal.
So it's very peculiar,
but it's very,
very.
It's a very,
very,
very common mythological notion.
The hero has to be,
the hero has to be a monster,
but a controlled monster.
Batman is like that,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's everywhere.
It's the story you always hear meaning
we have to be more precise.
Well,
that's a good,
that's a good question because one
question is,
you know,
you're kind of implicitly moral insofar
as you're socialized,
but that's sort of procedural.
It's just built into you.
This is different.
This is also becoming conscious of it
and expanding out your personality into
dimensions that it wouldn't normally
occupy.
So this happens to people all the time.
So for example,
lots of my clients,
my clinical clients are too agreeable
and I'm,
they're generally women because women
are more agreeable than men,
but not always because I've had
agreeable man,
his clients as well.
And what happens is they,
they're resentful and they don't know
how to stand up for themselves and it's
because they're very compassionate by
nature.
And so if you're entering into a
negotiation with them,
they'll let you win.
Well,
that's not so good because you know you
need to win too.
Especially if you're in an organization
of adults where there's,
there's a struggle,
right?
When you have kids can let them win.
Especially infants.
Like you have to let them win.
And that's partly why compassion is so
necessary.
But as a,
as a basis for negotiation between
adults,
it's like,
sorry,
it's insufficient.
You have to.
You have to be a bit of a monster so
that you can say no.
And so a lot of what you do in
psychotherapy is treat people's anxiety
and depression.
That's a huge chunk of it.
Help them straighten out the way they
think.
That's a huge chunk of it,
but another chunk of it is,
well,
let's toughen you up.
You know,
let's put you in a position where you
can bargain,
let's teach you how to assert yourself
and stand up for yourself and that's
assertiveness training and it's a huge
chunk of psychotherapy and you need to.
You need to learn it.
It's like because part of how you
regulate your interactions with other
people is to negotiate and you cannot
negotiate unless you can say no,
you can't do it.
And its causes conflict to say no,
and if you don't like conflict,
which is basically the definition of
being agreeable,
then you can't tolerate the conflict and
so then you can't negotiate on your own
behalf and so then you keep losing and
you're bullied and you know it's,
it's not good.
Then you get resentful and,
and it's really not good.
So you have to develop your inner
monster a little bit and,
and then that makes you a better person,
not a worse person.
It's weird,
it's weird,
but,
but that's just how it is.
Outside of that diagram is chaos itself,
and that's the chaos from which things
emerge.
Now,
I can't tell you much about that yet
because it's too damn complicated,
but I think the best way to think about
chaos is as potential.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's also that place you end up when you
don't know what to do.
It's the source of all things,
but it's also the terrible Predator,
the terrible eternal Predator that lurks
beyond the explored domain.
It's a winged dragon and it's winged.
Who knows why matter and spirit.
That's partly what it is,
and I'll explain that later.
It's also potentially the predatory
beast that's been after us for for
forever and the winged Predator that
picked us up from the sky.
So primates,
for example,
monkeys have some monkeys have three
specialized alarm cries,
one is for snakes,
and that usually means hit the trees and
then one's for leopards and that means
hit the trees and go out on a skinny
branch because the leopard can't get to
you.
And then there's one for like birds of
prey,
which means hide somewhere on the ground
so that you don't get picked off.
And it's like,
well,
that's what that is.
That's what that is.
And that's chaos and,
and it's expanded into much more than
that.
And then I showed you,
I don't remember if I showed you this,
but this is,
this is a symbolic representation of
mother,
father culture and the suffering
individual,
but it's all that's all positive.
There's no negative elements there,
but that's okay.
That's a partial representation.
And those things are sacred in some
sense because they are representative of
an ultimate reality of an ultimate
reality.
This sacrificial individual hear the
suffering individual.
Well,
that's pretty straightforward.
It's like that's what,
that's life,
that's suffering,
that's what happens to the individual.
And so everyone is looking at that.
There's a,
it has power,
that idea.
Well,
it's because you know,
culture supports the suffering
individual and cultures nested inside
benevolent nature and that's part of the
story of the world.
And it's this part of the story we're
trying to figure out and make
articulate.
We've been doing that for thousands of
years trying to make this story
articulate and it's not yet articulate
it.
It's only we're only getting it.
We're only getting it and we.
We basically do that now mostly with
movies and stories and fiction and that
sort of thing.
We still don't have it articulated.
I think young went close,
came closer than anyone else,
young and an Eric Norman who was one of
his students,
came closer than anyone else ever has to
actually articulate that and that's what
you was trying to do is to take all
these images,
archetypal images,
instinctual images and say,
well,
what do they mean?
What do they mean?
And he got a long ways on that.
Although his writing is quite obscure
and it's obscured because how the hell
are you going to explain an image like
that without being obscure?
It's like it's insanely complicated and
it's not linear.
It's not a linear thing that that's why
it's in a picture because a picture
presents everything at once and you want
to take that apart linearly.
Jesus,
it's just,
it's just impossible,
but we've been struggling to do that.
Really.
We've been struggling to do that from
the time we became self conscious,
you know,
what is the world about?
How should we live in it?
While that's a partial answer,
and it's a culture bound answer
obviously,
but you see archetipal representations
like this and many cultures,
so for example,
the image of the Virgin and child that
way predates Christianity.
Like the Egyptians,
that was isis and horace that goes back.
We have no idea how far thousands and
thousands of years before the emergence
of Judaism and Christianity way back
before that and no doubt back into
prehistory itself because a culture that
doesn't hold the mother and child as
sacred dies obviously because obviously
so it has to be held as a.
It has to be held as something that you
revere,
which at least means you don't kill
mothers and children and at least means
that.
And that's an instinct.
You know,
it's an instinct.
It violates you to do that.
And thank God.
All right,
let's take 15 minutes.
So I told you about this a little bit
last week,
but you know,
one of the motivations I had for
thinking the things that I've thought
through the motivation I had for
thinking them through was because,
well I like it,
it,
it seemed self evident to me,
let's say.
And I think that was partly from reading
young but not.
But that just helped me clarify it was
that it was sort of young's contention
that we had an organic development of a
metaphysical ethic that was embedded in,
in religious tradition and that
basically unfolded,
let's say in the West until about 1600,
1500,
something like that.
And then science emerged and we got
unbelievably technologically powerful on
and using a certain view of the world.
You know,
we're so technologically powerful but
we're still not very wise and that just
seems to me to be a bad combination.
And I thought about that a lot.
It's like,
okay,
well how do you handle the combination
of exceptional technological power and
and an impaired ethic,
let's say something like that
underdeveloped ethic or one even in
which you have no faith because you
know,
it seems that the foundational elements
of it are irrational.
They're there in mythology,
there in religion,
they don't fit well with the scientific
worldview.
How do you rectify that problem?
And while that's a tough problem,
you know,
it's a crazy problem and certainly it
was the problem that young was trying to
address.
There's no doubt about it.
And along with that went an associated
problem which,
which was,
you know,
what happened in the 20th century,
which was so awful and in so many
places,
it was just so unbelievably brutal and
terrible and it was perpetrated by
millions of people and they were
individual people and they weren't that
much different from normal people.
In fact,
they were normal people.
And so the other thing that struck me
was that it would be better if that sort
of thing didn't happen anymore.
And so I was trying to figure out what
the hell could possibly be done about
that.
And you know,
part of young's contention was while you
had to understand yourself as a monster,
if you were ever going to maintain some
control over the fact that you are in
fact the monster and that that could
come forth if the situation is correct.
It's like,
okay,
that seems reasonable and so,
well it seemed to me that,
you know,
people had to become wiser and of course
that's a very difficult thing to figure
out because you could even question
whether there is such a thing as wisdom,
you know?
And,
and then I thought,
well that's what the universities are
supposed to do.
Especially the humanities mostly in
particular,
it's supposed to make you wise.
That's what it's for.
And it's doing a terrible job of that.
In my estimation.
It's,
it's more decimating people as far as I
can tell and undermining whatever ethic
they have rather than making people
wise.
And.
But I think that we have to become wise.
I don't think there's a choice.
I think it's a matter of survival and
it's more than that because if you're
wise in your own life,
you're going to have a way better life
like incomparably better because you're.
You're gonna sleep soundly with a good
conscience at night and you know people
say that's worth more than money and
that's worth more than money.
I know lots of people who have lots of
money and let me tell you,
money protects you.
Your as well protected from the world by
money right now as you ever will be for
the rest of your life.